não posso referir a vocês não apresentar
é duas maneiras uma daquelas que não
darão conta é o suficiente
posso dirigir a vocês fazendo coelhinho
é tudo normal porque só acontece a mim ó
o deficiente sim uma vida cheia de luta
e conquistas
é mesmo uma forma positiva e não de uma
forma muito rápida peço que escolham
vocês já um treino para amanhã é forma
que querem que o falcão se na primeira
parte na segunda quem quer a primeira
foi o braço no ar e na segunda já
desconfiava
o tema é escolher primeiro certamente
nada tinha de dizer quem são os ladrões
chegou a uma marca tem dado o tom
natural de vila real são jovens de 40
anos era seguir em viseu há dois anos
é isso nem sempre é suficiente
hoje apenas deficientes nos oito anos
após uma operação à kuna
quando a energia a qualquer um já traz
um problema a mais curiosa curiosa após
a nado em vários médicos disseram que
teria que ser inclusiva na idade adulta
até lá para tentar fazer uma vida
completamente normal dentro do possível
porque é que o qual é aquilo que eu
tinha não seria nada demais não ser
apenas técnico uma parte mais de 80 numa
das minhas mãos placas e que não teria
problemas até é uma idade já avançada e
assim foi com todos nós
a escola aprendeu a escrever que minha
infância comportamento normal para verem
como foi tão normal
lembro me perfeitamente um dia há 32
anos atrás como se fosse um dia 25 de
dezembro
natal criava no domingo os pais era uma
família o meu pobre
tínhamos uma pequena quinta era dela
sobrevivemos onde ajudava já com oito
anos uma educação rigorosa metal e
religiosos
eu e minha família me sinto da parte da
manhã quando você andar uns amigos
brincar ali perto e minha mãe posso
brincar
elvis pode ser assim que o chamado
enquanto preparávamos mais alguns anos e
eu s fins rapidamente e entramos alguma
brincadeira fazemos uma pista no chão em
um carro à minha mãe morava ali perto
domingo metal pode ser mais um carro
preto e eu a ficar
o tom foi completamente diferente correr
estava no fundo do rabo e nunca tinha
corrido rápido chegou à casa estavam
quase todos no final do almoço o pai pra
mim e mesma forma lembra um cheirinho no
forno
pode ser que nessa história não sei se
sabem que isso é uma coisa qo tarefa se
o pocal se a galera pode mais foi ver
isto é nem tudo foi mau porque não comia
batatas e leonel frango mas pra onde eu
fui quem agora já pelas por mesa toda a
tarde inteira e só para verem que me
fazem o acompanhamento normal escola
entregou 5 e 6 que eu gosto do desporto
ter tentado fazenda
foi fazendo união os primeiros amigos
procissões que fazia na altura a minha
cara do anjinho não tinha nenhuma
por volta dos meus dez 12 anos quando
tóxico foi que enquanto o negócio hotel
desporto
quando o professor nos mandava fazer o
aquecimento para a aula de educação
física
andava sempre a 23 voltas ao campo
enquanto os colegas avança duas voltas
eu vá 45 e ela conseguiu meio próton
próton atinjo eu dava é minha
deficiência com qual time sub-11 uma
vantagem na foto outro para a contenção
o meu tronco é pequeno mas minhas pernas
eram muito grandes
comparadas com os meus amigos isto traz
uma vantagem que enquanto eo espaço ou 3
a 1 e acabou mesmo do cabo - passo que
os autores se uma equipa com mais três
amigos com os tais amigos das cáritas e
participar naquelas provas do dia 11 de
maio lhe 25 de abril provas que nos
fazem algumas ciladas
durante o primeiro ano do ciclo eo sul
isso depois como a família é pobre já
tinha perdido meu pai é os nove anos em
uma área segura pobre
deixei de estudar para trabalhar o barro
a morava comigo e com minha então é era
carpinteiro e eu fui passar vento eu
posso dizer que ela mas eu na altura que
hoje é maior na mínima por volta dos
meus 14 15 anos
o normal são também apresentadas favor é
que ela visitará até que estava no jogo
e ver uma bicicleta de ciclismo hoje
aqui é só você e ninguém queria mas na
altura estava no topo de gama e então
para além de incluir do atletismo que eu
já fazia é com regularidade
comecei também é fazer ciclismo e
participava também algumas provas
em vila real isto aconteceu até é um dos
meus acertar nos quase 18 momento em que
devemos vencer manhã casa para trabalhar
e depois de trabalho vinda é capaz de
ajudar a minha mãe na agricultura é
seguir nem faz um treino de bicicleta o
op ocorrer de 11 em pouco tempo pensava
em fazer tudo isso é alguém de quem já
visitou o site costume eu falo de mim é
dizer que eu estive duas vezes a segunda
ataque
quando fui internado no hospital são
joão no porto
meu problema assim a gravar vários
exames os médicos disseram que o momento
fazer uma cirurgia complicada mas em
todo o pará correr vai de 0 99%
possibilidade de ficar com o pé direito
tem problema falta na área e por aí fora
posso dizer que o culpado mesmo da
opressão ele é deitada na minha cama é
ea cantar aquela foto ali eu tenho
treinado nos próximos 12 meses e duas
semanas antes da realização de exames e
proverem eu estava na minha cama como
estava o time da casa à vontade da
galera é convivência que eu tinha com o
pessoal que trabalhava
nesses dois meses e meio que um jovem
completamente ativos em curso dentro de
quatro paredes com um pouco mais para
conquistar aqui passar 24 horas sobre 24
horas quem fazia lugar nas cadeiras de
rodas que via um ano no rosto e tentava
acertar os cavalinhos os enfermeiros
vinham e começaram a mandar ver comigo
maneira de sair com posicionaram em cima
de estradas cadeiras
elas são extremamente caras eu ficava
chateado porque eu ia fazer o virtuoso
seleção jogar às cartas que nos gémeos
normalmente eram todos os melhores eram
um passatempo
chego muito a pressão sobre o prazo
final no cro também tinham dito que era
suposto correr em uma apresentação
segura
e no dia após a operação dois dias do
cerol pra alguém vem ter comigo e mesmo
mario ao pré sal não correu tão bem
morangos posso correr e ganhar vai ter
que andar de cadeira de rodas pelo menos
no início e depois com um fisioterapeuta
afff vamos ver o que consegue qual foi o
primeiro pensamento para muita gente que
está há uns oito anos é de marcar numa
cadeira de rodas é o fim do mundo para
mim ter dito que os enfermeiros foram
comigo quando o médico diz vai ter que
ficar numa cadeira de rodas sabe qual é
o meu pensamento agora vão poder dizer o
marido sair
através disso o primeiro pensamento e
após cinco semanas do oitavo na mesma
posição naquela cama do hospital
o primeiro livro risos
e esse foi o da maneira que eu encontrei
de ser com isso mesmo uma pedra da droga
não é fácil ultrapassar o mentais e
físicas que ainda hoje na nossa
sociedade pode fazer mais algum tempo
algo então onde fiz algo bastante
universal e fiquei minimamente preparava
para o mundo lá fora
quando cheguei nos hospitais é procurar
trabalhos ou ganhar 5 euros por cada não
que houve nos passar férias nem todos
mas eu e mais alguns de vocês sem gastar
um tostão
um dia amou minha casa para o paok fé
tomou um café para um sonho do carro e
eu ia pelo meio da estrada
os passeios não eram acessíveis para o
sonhado carro olha pra mim ele não quer
jogar basquetebol em cadeira de rodas em
uma comunidade pra jogar basquetebol
ele conta ainda que a atual é que os
jogadores altos
dois metros de tal lançar a bola para
trouxe enorme
isto foi um pensamento 23 com dores a eu
até estava no metrô ana rosa o que é um
deles dentro do carro um sorriso de
orelha a orelha
r eu também ando de jogo eu oi ea partir
daí começou a tomar um café e ficamos
amigos até hoje
cheguei basquetebol branco 4 a 10 anos
64 equipas a nível nacional é nossa
situação também nos últimos anos veio
mas eu nunca gostei de pessoas têm mais
capacidade do que eu e fazem menos que
eu nunca me levarem custa-me a aceitar e
enviá-la jogadores tinham um tabu ao
menos do montado e executam e não fazia
um tempo seguiu com fazia ficar farto
bom
um dia um amigo meu irmão estávamos nós
estávamos dando mostras ao basquetebol
vamos dispensar isto é porque escrevemos
a maior demonstração do atletismo
atletismo boa estréia de rodas como eu
eles correram como queríamos cadeiras
especiais e vou acertar na imagem e que
dá um basta concluiu idade e eram
rapidíssimos eram trabalhar vamos fazer
isso sempre foi minha paixão não pudesse
emprestar uma postura mental só não me
custaram 1 disponibilizaram meios
prosseguiu vila real e concentra é
treinar com essa queda era velhinho mas
usava mais o de que eu mesmo pra sentir
o que era aquilo que eu queria fazer
como trabalhava na universidade de
trás-os-montes e alto douro
rapidamente a absurda turismo eduardo
coelho
ela também é exato a olímpica é com duas
participações em dois jogos olímpicos
não queria treinar e ao disponibilizar
os logo e até hoje temos feito uma dupla
de sucesso pelo erro quando o central
portista é preciso uma qualificação para
contermos as pessoas têm uma deficiência
idêntica é porque caso contrário é
injusto
assim ocorrer contra uma pessoa que
apenas tem uma perna
otto não tenha uma perna é é a
capacidade real é muito maior que a
minha
esta classificação b ter sido feita no
início quando eu comecei só passada já
foi feita e inspirações de estar um dia
nos jogos paraolímpicos mas posso dizer
com a explicação que eu tinha que estava
a fazer mínimos prata nos jogos
paraolímpicos que fazer três segundos
aos 100 metros ea classificação que eu
tenho que estar
é o que eu sou hoje está em fazer 19
segundos aos 100 metros é impossível
impensável para mim é onde estava a
conseguir é ter a inspiração de um dia
representar portugal ao mais alto nível
como isso foi posto a ser medicada
outras causas é tentar sensibilizar é é
a melhora geral para a circular os
deficientes não sabe a dia e para
dificultar nós temos de arranjar
trabalho iniciar no esporte e polifort
um dia em suas amigas precisavam da
ajuda estava numa carrinha para fazer
deslocar aos deficientes a minha camadas
nunca ou quase nunca sai no caso da
linha
eu não tinha dinheiro que o mapa
precisava ser divulgada
elas precisavam da ajuda voltado e
amigas
agora a atenção e se precisava nem
precisa ir para a pista é não precisava
vir antes de iniciar o meu patrocinador
na altura o futebol técnico e depois foi
entregue mas ainda tinha mais alguns
objetivos bateu recorde e alertar a
sociedade para a nossa circulantes e foi
um dia é brutal
todos os objetivos foram concluídos com
sucesso e podem pesquisar na internet e
exibe sobre isso 2008
porque nunca nos pode só falar nosso
problema de uma vez longe a longe em
2008 lembremos fazer uma premiação de r
ao fátima em cadeira de rodas sete dias
na estrada que ligava duas horas da
manhã os olhos estarão mais uma vez como
questão social sempre uma tensão e
tentar passar a palavra da nossa
veiculados em 2003 e depois do drama
pesado dizerem que não era possível
ouvir uma competição internacional você
quase ficava essa possibilidade surgiu
foi à holanda onde fui classificado os
coletivos não tiveram dúvidas nenhuma do
escalão que estava errado colocarem-nos
com um certo lobby gay conseguiu obter
uma medalha de bronze nos 100 metros não
estava preparado na própria pista é
importante em do estado da pista
veja os meus objetivos eram outros
sem treinar em são pedro do sul como
isto era um sonho
deixei são pensou previsão é visível a
melhor cidade para viver não há governo
estou cá agora já não está a trabalhar
diariamente faz treinos duas vezes por
dia de manhã e dotar três vezes por
semana vai estar no melhor nível 2014
estão em mínimos olímpicos
um amigo meu uma amiga ligou e perguntou
quem mais precisa
eu posso ver que uma brincadeira que eu
mais precisava ter ninguém na minha
conta eu me inscrever numa prova que
acabou a inscrição e e ernani uma
inscrição foi a suíça como perfis
mínimos paraolímpicos me deram acesso é
campeonatos da europa campeonato do
mundo e jogos paraolímpicos
logo nesse ano 2014 e terminar tropa ea
onde participei não ser nos 400 metros e
nos 100 metros costas nos 400 e ganhei a
prova mas foi desclassificado por ter
pisado na linha
2015 campeonato do mundo é para muita
gente
fiz um sétimo e um nono lugar nos 100 e
nos 400 metros
muita gente foi um fracasso sobre as
condições que a gente possa estar já
começávamos a outra forma e para
consolar porta-bandeiras é de uma ds uma
maior competição
nós temos no nosso desporto
o objetivo é prestar os jogos
paraolímpicos
é isso que estou a trabalhar para estar
em uma forma é topo de linha traz apoio
para para conseguir
espero conseguir seja vai nuclear
eu estou aqui fazer é que o que eu
espero que vocês também estejam fazer
estejam a correr pelos vossos sonhos
obrigado